you have a beautiful singing voice but  I've heard you also have a great a great  beatbox yes you can be yes okay well I I  guess it wasn't like biz markie one day  in the car and I just thought I could  like channel him and so I started to try  to beatbox and my driver told me if you  just say boots and skirts  you can beatbox but take out the vowels  so I started going right right and you  say thank you what it's a pretty good it  sounded like I was giving a bad [ __ ]  [Applause]  wrong because there's no such thing  yeah  noise you want yeah really doesn't  matter  and the enjoy it again with a different  sound can you do it oh wow  that was close sophomore year settle  down everybody let's move on to what can  I can i beatbox I do I do it I terrible  beatbox I but I discuss it that sounds  like a good [ __ ] that's a hydrolic  you